up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series today I am going to be
reacting to the real reason to not get
married but before I start don't forget
to subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification Bell that way you're
going to be notified of my daily videos
like the video on your way and that is
the most important metric that YouTube
uses to push out these live streams guys
let's try to get this video to a
thousand likes alright pull up the video
one of the central tenets of the men's
marriage strike is a reaction to the
Law's governing divorce and it is an
understandable position marriage and
subsequently divorce puts me in at some
very serious risk to name a few items
that have been a part of the Relentless
MRA and mgtow drum beat we have a loss
of children loss of property and income
and the loss of reputation that comes
within judiciously dispensed restraining
orders not to mention the possible loss
of Liberty and life that can be the
result of legal and social abuses that
stem from marriage and divorce even
feminists like the bovine facially
challenged Julie Bendel cautions women
from marriage because you know
patriarchy recipe
deny it all you want marriage is an
institution that has curtailed women's
freedom for centuries of course bindle
is wrong just like every other time she
opens her mouth but I suppose we should
thank her and maybe even support her
work if it makes women less inclined to
marry enough about Bendel though and
back to the topic at hand mras and
mgtows have been documenting the legal
hazards of marriage for a long time but
since they've done such a complete job I
wanted to do a video on some of the
other reasons this is mainly for the
benefit of men who manage to convince
themselves that they are somehow immune
to the legal traps or that the woman
they have chosen is a super cupcake who
would never Avail herself to the weapons
provided by the system that are designed
to destroy men and their children during
the process of a divorce
I start with a simple declaration if the
entirety of the corrupt family law
system were to be magically repaired in
an instant if restraining orders
required proof If child support oh my
gosh that's the crazy thing women can
literally get restraining orders with no
proof and the other thing is people will
always label mgtow as losers or whatever
but honestly a lot of the guys are just
like logical dudes who are like you know
what I don't want to lose my children
and half my stuff it's a sad reality but
I understand where they're coming from
alimony were ended and default shared
parenting became the law of the land
most men would still be better off not
married or even living with a female
partner especially those whose
relationships were founded on any notion
of romantic love so for just a few
minutes let's toss out the obvious
concerns about what the law can do to a
man where it concerns marriage let's
talk instead about long-term
relationships that are predicated on
romantic love especially where chivalry
is a part of the governing influence on
the relationship you know India has a
one percent divorce rate I don't think
romantic love leads to good outcomes
because it seems like romantic love is
like when the women have more choice
because before it would have been their
families right so it's like the more
choice we have and the more romance we
get it's like the worst outcomes there
are the more we'll leave our husbands
we're not feeling it the more you know
we'll marry a guy that really isn't a
great dad the more we'll go for actors
Entertainer whatever it is it's like it
doesn't seem like romantic love has good
outcome let's take a look first at how
most relationships still start
let me be brutally honest here about how
that happens even if most men won't be
brutally honest with themselves
relationships start with men competing
with each other to present themselves as
capable protectors and providers for
women straight out of the gate it is not
about your character your personality
your decency as a human being or Your
Capacity to love communicate or be a
good father it's not even about your
looks or your sexual prowess those items
count when women are looking for sex
much more so than when looking for
marriage which is to say that looks and
steadliness may well help her decide who
she's inclined to cheat on you with but
not much else I don't care who you are
these are the ground rules that form
your romantic involvement with women I'm
not saying that there aren't unicorns
out there I am saying however that they
are unicorns infinitesimally
rare exceptions to the rule and so far
we have not even factored in the current
self-aggrandizement and neurotic
entitlement that permeates Western
female culture take a look at this
series of images
unless you have an unusually strong
Constitution a higher than usual Acumen
for putting an end to princess
or unless you have a magical net and
catch yourself I didn't even realize
that's kind of like you're submitting to
her that's what it looks
I guess I just got red pill than
proposal of a unicorn you are not just
looking at marriage proposals you are
looking at the model for the entirety of
married life what used to be something
symbolic a metaphor for the ability and
willingness to be a provider is now
taken literally by Legions of women to
them this doesn't say I love you and
want to marry you it says I bring gifts
because I owe you because your wants are
more important than my needs and her
response isn't just yes I will marry you
it is your I'm right you owe me and you
will spend the rest of your life proving
it if you don't believe that then I can
only urge you to take a look at the
lives of so many married men who end up
cohabitating with lazy self-absorbed
heritans whose only real expertise in
life is sloth and haranguing their
husbands into working ever harder to
meet their childish demands is there
gonna be a red carpet like in Miami oh
my gosh the average first marriage is
like 20K I was thinking about this I was
like guys would be a lot more willing to
put a ring on it faster if they knew
they could just go to the courthouse
like what I was thinking about this what
do we need all these people there uh you
really just need your close friends your
close families but women want to do
these like extravagant huge weddings and
they don't even think about the marriage
they don't even think about like girls
don't even think about what type of
marriage they want except a traditional
when it benefits me marriage
she's humor and Jerry by window shopping
for apartments
full
donkey if I can compromise and get her a
house I'll make her very happy they tend
toward emotional psychological and
sometimes even physical events mind you
I'm not talking about a
in the classical sense I'm talking about
the everyday mundane type of equipment
typically acclimate themselves to with
women here is one rule that I do have
and it's the 2575 rule which means that
you should be talking 25 of the time and
a woman should be talking 75 of the time
women getting their way about everything
is one such form of a it is the kind
that men free well and this is because
of how the contracts are set up it's
like women are paid to leave so of
course the guy's always going to be
trying to make her happy because he
doesn't want her to leave and take half
a he's not trying to do that really
end up creating euphemisms for like I
actually I talked to a woman today she
was Catholic or not Catholic Christian
and she was telling me how women's
natural like or like from Eve from the
dawn of time was just to take control
and then ruin everything kind of like we
did in Eden you know we we got the
criticized or like I don't know I forgot
how she phrased it but it was like
basically that women are natural
inclination is like to criticize and
kind of
disobey yeah that's our natural
inclination is to disobey and we have to
fight it uh because we think we know
best and we don't yeah that's just how
women are well yes that is just how
women are the question is really why men
are so quick to put up with it for
instance one of the things that most men
will get used to in so-called successful
marriages is that every major decision
that impacts their lives is going to be
made by her yeah women make 80 of
consumer buying decisions and that says
so much because that includes like home
home buying that includes cars like it's
all the big financial decisions are made
by women any real estate agent will be
able to tell you oh look at that we're
on the same wave that when a couple
purchases a home usually the most
significant and costly investment of
their lives it is the woman who's going
to make the decision even if you are one
paying for the home agents know you
probably don't count for much in the
equation they are selling to her not you
or even you as part of a couple they
pitched the bit
you're just the wallet this isn't
limited to homes according to Martha
Barletta author of marketing to women
U.S women control or influence seven
trillion dollars in consumer spending
annually and make 85 of all purchase
decisions notice that the 85 percent
figure is about all purchase decisions
not just the home that means at least
statistically speaking the moment you
get married the Lion's Share of your
purchasing decisions are no longer yours
they're in her hands she she will decide
on the car or cars you own the furniture
you buy the vacations you take even the
clothing and the food you shop for ever
heard which is crazy because it's like
we don't even know what we want we don't
even we're the most indecisive creature
The Stereotype of the couple in the mall
him carrying all the packages and her
carrying the credit card oh my gosh
that's so true well it's not an urban
myth Maul mules are a thing the more you
examine the realities of marriage and
divorce it becomes clear that divorce is
just a demarcation line between her
spending your money while you're still
allowed to sleep in the home and
spending your money after you've been
kicked out okay you might say you're not
really a materialistic guy and you don't
mind if she spends your horn to earn
cash in ways that please her I happen to
think that is the rationale of guys
whose spines resemble overdone ribbons
of fettuccine and have to find a way to
rationalize their way out of looking at
that but I'm not here to argue about it
the fact is that it does not end with
just turning you into an ATM in many
cases you are turned into an ATM that is
not allowed to take up too much room in
her house oh my gosh I've totally seen
those and that's the thing like people
demonize the mgtow guys like you can't
even see where they're coming from this
is the house he pays for and now he
can't even you know get half the bed
even when you technically live there
after years of hearing from Men Who
learn to cope with their being viewed as
a utility who adjusts to homes with hers
and hers closets hers and her sinks and
hers and hers spending money The
Disappearing space becomes just another
thing they rationalize at some sort of
noble sacrifice in the name of being a
good man they have to apply that same
rationale I suppose as they watch their
friends fade away their interests and
their Hobbies gather dust and as they
watch their whole lives reduced to
nothing more than an afterthought in the
realm of satisfying whatever it is she
wants just as they will have to put the
rationalization hamster on steroids to
conjure up a way to live with the fact
that when all is said and done she will
still be highly unlikely to approve of
him and there's the rub gents life with
the greatest majority of modern women is
nothing less than a battle for your soul
these women were born and raised in a
culture that told them men owed them the
moon and stars they have been fed they
think about it they always say you're a
princess from a young age so we grew up
thinking they were actually princesses
like okay think about Cinderella
Cinderella this woman was sitting at
home average chick let's just be honest
average chick sitting at home and this
Prince showed a better doorstep this is
what we're taught Sleeping Beauty was
literally asleep what did any of the
princesses bring to the table I can't
think of it actually I think I think
Cinderella was a good cleaner a
narrative by feminists and
traditionalist alike that tells them
they are entitled to them treating a man
like a servant and a butler is part of
the natural order when you hear mras and
mgtows referring to marriage as a form
of slavery they are not just talking
about what the state will do to you
sadly the great majority of men have
been complicit in enabling this problem
gentlemen this is one of the universal
challenges of marriage and one of the
universal dangers they're in losing
yourself to the role of matrimonial
Patsy you may consider it a pittance to
pay when you're 21 insecure and willing
to do anything for the illusion of love
from the object of your desires you may
even be willing to overlook the fact
that even in your illusion there's no
room for your self-respect you will see
it very differently at 41 with two
decades of your life wasted on someone
who looks at you like a pack animal even
then it may be hard to look yourself in
the mirror and see that you did it to
yourself I reiterate that there are a
few unicorns out there but of course in
the throes of infatuation and romantic
love every man thinks I know every man
thinks his girl's unicorn and that's the
thing and this issue is guys are willing
to put up with stuff but the problem is
they don't even get a guarantee like
they don't even get a guarantee that
she's not gonna leave you know we'll try
to demonize these guys but you kind of
understand where they're coming from
does just what he has found nearly every
last one of them is wrong it's true that
we need to revamp family law before
marriage will ever be safe again we also
need to revamp women with the growth of
the new narrative men are starting to
revamp themselves I'm going to end this
talk with a story where he once told me
by a psychiatrist that I used to work
with who happened to be Jewish he
explained to me the difference between a
schlemile a schlamazel and a schmuck
Paul he said say there are three guys
having dinner together the slimile is
the guy who spills his soup the
schlemazel is the guy he spills it on
the schmuck is the guy who cleans it up
so in closing let me say this please
don't be a schmuck don't don't get
married not until some very big changes
have happened in the world in the
meantime do your part to make those
changes happen I understand where he's
coming from and that's the thing a lot
of women don't understand why men are
going their own way yet ninety percent
of us are on birth control one out of
three is an STD one out of three has had
an abortion okay
um the average body count they say is
five to eight but I've seen some numbers
that college women admit to sleeping
with seven dudes in a year so I mean do
the math with that uh average age first
marriage in the UK is 31. so I mean it
can we really blame them and I'm not
saying there are not good women they're
absolutely good women that you know will
be with you through thick and thin I've
honestly interviewed some really awesome
and amazing wives but the issue that we
get into is I just think the quality
overall is that you know lower than it's
ever been in all of history so you know
um guys let me know what you think in
the comments like the video on your out
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell I'll talk to you next
time